[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
game that can only be described as
well not maybe as uh great as the game
that uh magnus played against max
deutsch but it's
you know almost almost up there with
with the great ones and it's been played
uh
in uh 18 uh in 1911 sorry about that in
1911 between edward lasker
uh and sir george allen thomas uh and
i've already made a video on this game
but that was some four years ago
uh this actually comes as a suggestion
uh from a user on twitter named prathik
and he said that i should cover this
game that it's uh it's a very nice game
but i already covered it so i thought
nah
but then i checked when i covered it it
was in 2017
and i know most of you guys weren't uh
following the channel back then in uh
2017 and uh
well this is uh like i said one of the
greatest games
ever so i decided to show it again so
you guys can enjoy it
in 60 frames per second and with with
some
additional story and maybe uh you know a
a a line analysis or two to follow it up
but if you guys want to check out the
original video that's also cool
uh it's going to be the first link in
the description below so before we check
out the game i
know for those of you who are maybe new
to chess this is not the world champion
emmanuel alaska this is edward lasker
they might be related i've searched a
little bit
but uh if they are they're not very
closely related but
they kind of i i guess they think they
are related but
you know doesn't really matter uh for
the game but he was also
a very strong player not as strong
obviously as world champion emmanuel
asker uh but he's playing uh against
their george allen thomas like we said
he's uh
well both a chess player and a really
really awesome tennis player
and uh well let's just dive straight
into it but before we check out the game
as the game is very short i would just
like to
read a very very short part from the
chess
secrets book that edward lasker wrote uh
so it's
regarding this uh particular encounter
uh he says that
this was not a tournament game but a
so-called five-minute game and the
five-minute game
uh in those days meant that uh it
doesn't matter what the time form it was
if you played a 10 minute game 15
minutes uh 20 minutes half an hour an
hour hour and a half
but uh you could never allow you to
yourself to have five minutes less than
your opponent so for example if uh
you both had half an hour on the clock
uh and if your opponent had like
25 minutes at some point you could never
allow your clock to go
below 20 minutes so it could only be
within those
five minutes so that's like this they
called it the english
five i did not know of this uh so i
imagine some of you don't know um
uh about it as well and uh
it's so it's a really interesting time
format like you can
spend a lot of time but never more than
you know dropping lower than five
minutes so it's a
really really interesting concept i've
never heard anyone uh
using this in in modern days but okay uh
that was the time format and it was
uh like the books uh says very popular
in the city of london chess club where
this game was played in 1911. i have
some sort of a sentimental attachment to
it says
edward lasker and uh not only because it
is the most beautiful game i ever
succeeded in winning but because it was
the first game i played in england
on the day i arrived here c6 from an
awful channel crossing and without
knowing a word of english as always
when i find myself in a foreign country
my first visit was to the leading chess
club that's what you should always do
when you visit the
country you should always check out any
chess clubs in your vicinity
and there the uh
as he says there the chess player is
sure to find some
friendly advice i was introduced to many
members whose names
i did not understand and one of them
invited me to play a game with him at
the time i was quite unaware
that he was sir george thomas this
gentleman here the champion of the club
and later british champion
uh and uh the rules were explained to
him
sort of the the english five and the
well the the game commenced so uh laskar
with the white pieces opened the game
with
d4 uh we have f5 and
this is the dutch defense uh sorry about
that and this is
still played today you can uh try uh
you know variety of moves g3 being the
most popular you can go c
for knight c3 knight to f3 so a lot of
interesting ways to meet
this idea uh but here alaska went for e4
now this is the staunton gambit uh
actually uh by the famous howard
staunton uh and you're giving up your
central pawn
uh for for black's f-pawn for some rapid
development and
the the absolute best move here is just
to capture the e pawn
uh there's no no question about it so if
captures an e4 you trade your
uh f pawn for white's very strong
central pawn with knight to c3
developing and now knight to f6
defending this e4 pawn
we have bishop to g5 now attacking the
knight with maybe ideas of captures and
uh regaining your material but now e6 by
black and this is already
maybe a bit too adventurous g6 maybe
would have
been better so if white wants to win
back uh the pawn he will at least have
to give up the bishop pair but okay we
have e6 here
uh and now uh that the the knight is
actually pinned we can capture on e4 so
knight captures on e4 uh bishop to e7
and now uh here we have a trade bishop
captures bishop captures and
knight to f3 and here we have castles
uh bishop to d3 every move another piece
being developed that's how you should
always try and
play and okay uh black goes b6
now black wants to put his light square
bishop on this long diagonal
and it's going to be an excellent piece
there so here at knights the e5
and the black just continues with bishop
to b7 although here
uh you should definitely consider
trading here captures captures then
knight c6 and
uh you don't have a uh you know any any
troubles whatsoever but instead after
knight to e5 we have bishop to b7
still nothing you know terrible has
happened but here
queen to h5 and already uh you can see
this if you know this game i'm sure you
remember this position
but like i said it's been like over four
years since i've shown it
and uh it's uh it's a legendary position
and here
uh if you haven't captured an e5 now you
should capture on e5 now because now
bishop captures an e5
uh it's like the most important move
that was never played
because uh well you have to play
something now and here
you don't have a you don't have any way
of continuing the attack because you
would probably go something like this
open up an attack towards h7 and after
you block this then you're gonna
recapture with the queen
so then the game continues knight c6
attacks the queen queen g3
and so on however after queen to h5 here
uh black played queen to e7 and this is
the move
sir george allen thomas will remember
for the rest of his life
as uh with this move he allows one of
the
most beautiful uh series of moves that
were ever played
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this uh
incredible idea for edward lasker well i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh
finding uh such an amazing amazing uh
move
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's actually
queen captures on h7 and this is the
start of the
of the well one of the most incredible
king hunts uh the king comes
all the way from g8 uh to you you're
gonna see where
and you don't have any moves the f7
square is covered by the knight so the
queen sacrifice
and must be accepted so king captures on
h7 was played
and now of course comes the double check
uh the bishop is x-raying that king so
knight captures on f6 with a double
check so black
the only move is the as uh move the king
that's oh you know that there's a saying
about this even the even the bravest
king
flees in in the sight of a double check
or something like that um
i'm sure you guys know it better uh and
now if you go back then it just knights
the g6 checkmate so
you cannot go back you have to go
forward so after this uh double check
king to h6 was played
but now comes knight e to g4 the only
good way to continue this
and now the king must come closer the
bishop still controls this entire
diagonal
and you'll discover by the knight so g5
is the only square left for the king so
king g5
and now the king hunt continues here we
have h4 with
check king to f4 and now even g3
with check we have king to f3 and now of
course
bishop to e2 this comes with check uh
later it was uh suggested
to lasker that he could have won this
even faster by just uh
playing castles uh or king to f1 uh just
uh you know
uh preventing the king from reaching the
g2 square but
uh as the story goes uh alaska heard her
well was aware of morphy's game where
morphy i guess uh
checkmated his opponent by castling so
he wanted to avoid
something like that so uh instead he did
it differently he played bishop to e2
check king to g2 and now rook the h2
check
now the only square left for the king is
king to g1 and now of course
while you can castle for checkmate here
alaska played
king to d2 and he delivered this final
check from the rook on a1
and it is now only as a move 18 that the
black king is in checkmate and there are
no squares for him to go to
so as this was uh quite uh quite a lot
of moves for the for the black king i'm
just going to show it
one more time uh just this combination
after queen to e7
look at this queen captures on h7 nice
in slow motion oops
i dropped it and there we go uh just
captures now a double check
we force the king forward and now we
continue the onslaught knight to g4
check
king g5 h4 king for g3 king of three
bishop e to check king here
and now of course king rook to h2 check
king to g1 and king to d2 a most amazing
checkmate
uh so that's uh that's basically it uh
there wasn't uh
all that much more analysis that i could
have done for the game but i
i did include this story for you guys to
enjoy even though
i'm sure most of you haven't seen this
game but i could be wrong i guess
you know it's a very popular game uh but
you know i i never trust myself in these
kind of situations i always um you know
uh
will uh imagine the worst and then you
know
if it turns out to be better then it's
better uh and also a fun fact
that uh you can check out on edward
lasker's wikipedia page that i've never
heard of
it says that uh in 1921 to 1923 uh he
invented a mechanical breast pump
which saved many premature infants lives
and made lasker much money
although it caused his friends to refer
to him uh facetiously as
the chest master uh the chess player
uh so very very interesting stuff i've
never heard of this uh before
uh but yeah this is uh mortal and uh for
those of you who are new to chess
not the world champion emmanuel asker
this is edward lasker
uh also an incredibly strong player and
a very
versatile gentleman uh and this is his
immortal game
uh so yeah uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank uh
sean javid eduardo
uh paguaga eric thomas uh andrew crowe
and balcovich enterprises for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and
do check out the video from 2017 if you
guys are into that
first link in the description below see
you soon